there is another audio recording of
House minority leader Kevin McCarthy
who's a republican making it very clear
that he wants Trump out this is truly
incredible stuff and it actually it's
not improving my opinion of McCarthy
it's actually worsening it and I'll
explain why new audio reports CNN
McCarthy said 25th amendment takes too
long
in other words the 25th Amendment would
take too long to remove Trump he wanted
as a republican who publicly supported
Trump privately McCarthy wanted Trump
removed wanted to reach out to Biden
after the January 6th attack this is
incredible
house Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
discussed the 25th Amendment this is a
mechanism to remove a sitting president
on a call with Republican leadership
days after the January 6 2021 attack on
the Capitol and said the process takes
too long according to audio obtained by
the New York Times and shared with CNN
he also said he wanted to reach out to
then president-elect Biden to hope for a
smooth transition and said he thought an
impeachment would further divide the
nation let's listen to that audio
revealed yesterday to CNN by the New
York Times reporters this is incredible
stuff
yeah but what the president did is
atrocious isn't totally wrong
um at the standpoint we're 12 days away
I mean at one point I'd like to advice
if you have an impeachment and you're
stuck sitting in the Senate and he needs
cabinet members you've got secretary
fans he's got a lot of things
from the perspective you put everything
else to write this country is very very
divide I do say to the impeachment
divides the nation further and continues
to provide these great
um that's why I want to reach out to
Biden I wanted the president to leave
the Bible but that's not going to happen
I want to see about us leaders advising
and sitting down like a smooth
transition show
we continue to keep those statements
going
um so hopefully I need to talk to Pelosi
but he's gonna I hopefully he calls me
today
um
and see if we can start that process
this is incredible stuff truly
hope okay that's the end of the clip uh
this makes these people look way worse
so every time we we learn something like
this
there's kind of two perspectives right
there's well one perspective is these
people aren't as crazy as we thought in
the sense that they realized how
dangerous Trump was and they actually
did want him gone that's one perspective
they're not as bad the other perspective
is these people are even worse because
it's not that they genuinely believed
Trump won and the riots were good and
all this different stuff they knew the
opposite was true but they continued
publicly saying uh the things that they
had to say in order to stay in Trump's
good graces or whatever the case may be
I believe that the latter is accurate
these people are worse because Kevin
McCarthy knew better he knew better he
was saying it he was on the phone with
Liz Cheney he was on the phone with
whoever and he continued to Pander and
to risk American democracy because of
whatever selfish or self-centered
reasons made him do it publicly he's
says oh it was atrocious and it was
totally wrong what Trump did we got to
look at the 25th Amendment
um and yet publicly he just continued to
do his thing and say no everything's
good Republicans are good everything's
good so is it a desire for power and
money and continuing to have access to
the president that influenced it is
there some connection and we're
speculating here between whatever made
Ted Cruz and Lindsey Graham 180 on Trump
remember the the those were not people
who ever supported Trump early
and then all of a sudden they love Trump
they think he's great is there some
connection between that and whatever
kept McCarthy publicly supporting Trump
could it be as simple as polling they
saw listen most of the base supports
this guy so we've got to support this
guy all of this confirms McCarthy is
sane enough to know about the toxicity
and the atrocity of trump and yet he
still actively chose to allow it and
that makes him I believe worse than if
he was a True Believer and this kind of
gets back to the conversation we've been
having for a week or two now about
what's worse the True Believers or the
false Believers the 25th amendment was
exactly for situations like these where
the president has become so compromised
he can't think straight he can't
discharge his duty as president of the
United States he's lost his mind and
some of the people closest to him
I guess they knew it had been enough but
they chose not to act and they continue
Republicans do to tell Democrats now
that they've got to clean up the mess
that it's actually Republicans and
trumpists who created now one other
question we've been playing these
recordings of Kevin McCarthy for weeks
now
has Fox even talked about them
do Fox News viewers even know that these
recordings exist I genuinely don't know
the answer I mean it's not like I sit
around and watch Fox do they have any
idea
of what we've learned from these
recordings over the last few weeks I
don't know the answer to that but if the
answer is no this goes to our story
about two Americas that exist and it's a
very very disturbing stuff let me know
your thoughts you can find me on Twitter
at dpacman do you know the fastest
growing crime in the United States for
years the rate of this crime has been
surging the crime is identity theft and
it happens way more often than you might
think it's happened to me I've talked
about this on the show before and it can
be really bad sometimes you get a text
that your email password has been
changed your bank calls about unusual
activity your PayPal account is getting
drained and it can happen very very
quickly to keep my accounts protected I
use Aura our sponsor Aura is Identity
Theft Protection fraud monitoring and
password management all wrapped into one
Aura monitors the dark web for your
information they monitor your credit
card they monitor your bank accounts my
subscription to Aura gives me peace of
mind protects my devices it protects all
of my different accounts and I can
monitor everything in one place on the
app if I get attacked or actually takes
action to prevent and resolve the issues
in real time and Aura is letting my
audience try it completely free for 14
days go to aura.com Pacman the link is
down below